the ukrainian president as you know is
pleading with the u.s poland and other
allies to give ukraine more warplanes to
help fight the russian invaders but
moscow has warned that any country
hosting ukrainian combat aircraft could
be viewed as a party to this conflict
wijajang is at the white house with more
on that part of the story good morning
to you
good morning to you gail and good
morning to everybody the biden
administration and lawmakers from both
parties have said that putting u.s
planes in the sky to enforce a no-fly
zone could lead to world war iii but
they are open to helping ukraine get
more fighter jets to protect itself and
president biden is coming around to
using another financial tool to punish
russia banning its oil
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
made a passionate plea directly to u.s
senators on a zoom call over the weekend
making a case for america to stop
purchasing russian oil and to supply
military planes and support he said
ukrainian jets were destroyed on the
first day of the invasion we're
committed to helping ukraine defend
itself while president biden is not
budging on his refusal to back a no-fly
zone secretary of state anthony blinken
said on face the nation that the
administration does support poland
sending fighter jets to ukraine that
gets a green light in fact we're talking
with our polish friends right now about
what we might be able to do to backfill
their needs if in fact they choose to
provide these fighter jets to to the
ukrainians the white house is also
reviewing options for an embargo on
russian oil and house speaker nancy
pelosi wrote to colleagues sunday that a
new bill would ban the import of russian
oil and energy products which appears to
have bipartisan support in both chambers
of congress this notion that somehow
banning russian oil would raise prices
on american consumers is an admission
that this guy that this killer that this
butcher vladimir putin has leverage over
us i would absolutely support cutting
off russian oil to the united states
meanwhile the list of private companies
cutting ties with russia is mounting
visa mastercard and american express are
boycotting business there tick tock is
blocking users on its platform in russia
and netflix announced it has suspended
service
tensions continued to escalate saturday
after the state department urged
americans to depart russia immediately
the warning came on the same day that
russian officials announced they had
detained olympic gold medalist and wnba
star brittany griner last month the 31
year old accused of having vape
cartridges with hashish oil in her
luggage remains in russian custody
greiner had been playing in russia
overseas this winter now asked about her
case secretary blinken said more broadly
that a team there is helping all
detained americans however they can he
also added that the u.s had advised its
citizens not to travel to russia and
again telling them to get out now if
they can nate
ouija thank you